on a calm sunny day the izat's fire
power station in Bavaria seems
unremarkable but a closer inspection
shows its energy source is nuclear one
of three reactors in Germany which
together provide around six percent of
the country's energy and which were due
to be switched off permanently but with
Russian gas pipelines switched off its
coal embargoed and its oil soon to
follow the German government has serious
worries about a sudden potential energy
shortage in Winter
these three nuclear power plants that we
have in operation today can actually
continue to operate over the next year
until April 15th as far as their
respective capacities allow that will
have to be assessed individually but
this makes several things clear at the
same time some analysts believe
prolonging the life of these reactors
Beyond April would be difficult the
German industry has been winding up
their activities for the past 10 years
they have essentially sent a Personnel
away highly skilled workers which you
can't just reactivate like that so
there's a whole bunch of questions the
role of nuclear power polarizes politics
here the main opposition party says the
three reactors should not be switched
off in April the center right free
Democrats who are part of the federal
government are not ideologically opposed
to that and the far-right RFD goes
further and says new reactors should be
built all of which means that there may
well be a de facto pro-nuclear power
majority in Parliament it's something
many in the governing Greens in espida
have spent their political lives
campaigning against there's a well a
huge portion of resistance within the
greens and the SPD to again reconsider
this exit but of course energy Supply
price is are going through the roofs in
Germany and and citizens are calling for
Relief the chancellor says there is
enough gas to get through the worst of
winter and that nuclear is only a
short-term solution should the situation
deteriorate but polls suggest many
people are not so sure Dominic Kane Al
Jazeera Berlin